like i did adr for robert downey jr for  a couple movies and i just go when when  it came through i was like i've never  tried to do that and i tried and i was  like okay cool i can kind of do like a a  decent one you know what does he how  does he talk so we're sitting here on uh  so rdj here so iron man one iron man two  there's obviously more moves i've done  heart and souls uh chocolate i  auditioned for it but johnny depp got it  but you know kerma she [ __ ] in his bed  well we don't know it tastes like human  [ __ ] i didn't eat it but i heard he did  so anyway so we're here on inside of you  or inside with you are we inside of  we're inside together the house uh the  rosenbaum bill it's a very nice house a  lot of puppets not enough puppets  someone say but um